[Music]
braden is with us braden's in memphis hi
brayden welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so i just got a quick question for you
so me and my wife are um we're both 22
and we're debt-free like as a month and
a half ago
and uh way to go
so
we've
kind of just been chilling you know
relaxing and now i'm kind of just i'm so
used to being gazelle contin uh gazelle
in tents now i'm kind of feeling like i
don't know what to do i'm honestly kind
of getting a little bored because i
don't have like an object
to achieve good for you so i'm invested
into retirement and everything but i'm
just wondering kind of like what's next
um you know what should i what kind of
goal should i sit
so you have a paid for house
yes sir what's it worth
about 215. what do you guys do for a
living
i work for my dad as a herbiculturist
is that your long-term dream
take over the business or do you wanna
do something else
yeah i'm gonna take it over good okay
what's your wife do
she actually just does a little bit of
photography on the side but takes care
of what you make
i make around 80. okay okay cool
so you have a 215 000 house you make 80
you're 22 years old and you have zero
debt of any kind yes
she makes about 30. so 110 total okay
110 household income okay cool yeah all
right
well i think you start laying out you
know what are some of our goals there
are three things you can do with money
and you should always do these three
things you can be generous with it
giving it
uh you can enjoy it and you should
and you can invest it and you should and
you do need to set some very clear
high definition very uber clear goals of
where you want to be and it can be a
random thing i want to have a million
dollar net worth i want to move to a
house it's 600 000 for my house it's 200
i want to pay cash for that difference
that's 400 now how long am i going to do
that well it's going to take me
six years or whatever i don't know right
and you start laying your numbers out
and then you've got something to plop
that money towards each time it comes in
and um
because right now the money is just kind
of wandering it doesn't have an
assignment when it comes in and you're
bored and you feel disjointed a little
bit but you need to have it a you know i
i'm one of my goals was to give away a
million dollars in a year one time
and then once i did that one of my other
goals was to give away a million dollars
in one day
and i've been able to hit both those so
i had to have a new goal on my
generosity goals
and so um pretty cool it's been fun so
you gotta you know you start but i'm i'm
like three times older than you so
you've got plenty of time to pull this
off